our thoughts and prayers with the very
families affected
[Music]
these movements are consistent with
deliberate action by someone on the
plane
the operation has entered a new phase
the search was already a highly complex
multinational effort it has now become
even more difficult my emotion is going
through what a roller coaster ride
in the early hours of Saturday the 8th
of March Malaysia Airlines flight 370
vanished into the night an hour into its
journey came forth words from the flight
deck okay
received good night and with that it was
gone this program will look back at the
search so far and how it has expanded to
cover one tenth of the world's surface
we will also examine what we know about
the pilots and the passengers on board
and explore the theories of what might
have happened to this plane on what
should have been a routine flight from
Kuala Lumpur to Beijing rescue teams
from 25 countries are now involved in
the search for the missing plane dozens
of aircraft and ships are scouring the
ocean for a sign a clue anything what
we're doing is producing our best
estimate of the most likely place to
search but I would hasten to add it is
far from very precise the operation
initially centered around the last-known
location of the aircraft
flight mh370 took off from Kuala Lumpur
Airport bound for Beijing on Saturday
the 8th of March at 12:41 a.m. local
time the last transmission from the
planes onboard communication system
ACARS was previously said to be 7
minutes past 1:00 we've now learned that
it could have been switched off up to 30
minutes later it has also been revealed
that the last verbal contact from the
plane to air traffic control was at 19
minutes past 111 minutes earlier than
previously said and it is emerge for the
first time as well that the last words
from the cockpit were spoken by the
copilot before the planes transponder
which tracks it was turned off at 1:30
a.m. air traffic control in Kuala lumper
spoke to the flight deck we've handed
you over to Ho Chi Minh air traffic
control was the message okay received
good night was the reply it was the last
anyone heard
how difficult is your task
[Music]
very difficult
wherever we never give up you try to
search
[Applause]
whatever the fate of flight mh370 the
pilots will have played some role fifty
three-year-old zaharie ahmad shah was
the captain that evening he is a vastly
experienced pilot with more than
eighteen and a half thousand flying
hours under his belt was a volunteer in
the community program that I organized
at the end of the program there was this
guy helping to stack chest to clean up
the place and not having met him before
I asked who is this man and I was told
he works for Malaysian Airlines I went
to say thank you to him and he
introduced himself he didn't mean his
name Karan when I saw he was a captain
of a triple 7 you know that's the kind
of humble person that captain zaharie's
captain zaharie's family have now made
and released this video asking for him
to come home to them soon he was hired
by Malaysia Airlines directly out of
school and trained by Malaysia Airlines
he was one of the original triple7 fleet
captains you know he's great guy you
know this is a great pilot you know I
think attest to his experience of 18,000
hours of flying great career the first
officer was Fariq abdul hamid he's 27
years old and joined Malaysia Airlines
in 2007 he was fairly new to this model
of aircraft a Boeing triple7 200 initial
investigation indicated worse than cool
pilots the last time
CCTV shows the two men going through
security on their way to board the
flight that evening we are told they did
not specifically request to fly together
that night police have started searching
their homes
talking to friends and neighbors
this is captain zaharie's house what a
smart compound on the outskirts of Kuala
lumper his maid looks out at the door
it's hard to believe that he would have
didn't to do anything like that you know
to you know like the speculation of
pilot suicide or a pilot hijacking I
just can't imagine his with his
character and what we knew of him it
just wouldn't make any sense that he
would have anything to do with any sort
of deliberate action on his part
they found this simulator in captain
zaharie's house the data on it is now
being analyzed for clues my emotion is
going through what I call the
roller-coaster ride when you see all of
us a potential answer a positive answer
he goes up and then there's no it goes
back down and go salmon goes down and
yeah it's difficult and I can just
sympathize with the families of the
people involved now because they must be
going through much much more difficult
time his piloting skills would be great
you know and and I think he would do
anything he could to preserve the lives
of his passengers and in the cargo the
property of Malaysia Airlines he was
really proud of that company in
but the captain and co-pilot are not the
only people who are on the plane two
have come under investigation early on
to name stood out an Austrian called
Cristian Cosel the other an Italian
could luigi morality they shouldn't have
been listed on the planes manifest they
weren't on board their passports had
been stolen in Thailand it would appear
that they had then been used by these
two men purine or Mohammed II and Della
Valle Syed Mohammad Reza Iranians trying
to claim asylum in Europe but they have
no known links to terrorism we know that
once these two individuals arrived in
Kuala Lumpur on the 28th of February
they boarded flight 370 using different
identities inevitably after all this
time and with no clue as to where the
plane is the Malaysian investigators are
coming under scrutiny
they hold daily news conferences but
with no explanation the frustration on
all sides is growing a week into the
investigation it was the Malaysian Prime
Minister himself who announced the most
dramatic development to date which also
effectively put the search back to
square one it then flew in a westerly
direction back over Peninsular Malaysia
before turning Northwest until the point
at which it left military primary radar
coverage these movements are consistent
with deliberate action by someone on the
plane in Beijing some relatives have
threatened to go on hunger strike if
they don't get more information if the
families had spoken to had allowed to
speak to senior officials from the
Malaysian government I think they would
have felt a little bit more reassured
obviously you can't imagine what they
must be going through now but if there
was a dedicated team to look after their
needs including psychologists if
necessary and just to give a timely flow
of information whatever was possible and
to make sure their needs are attended to
on the ground a former Malaysian
Transport Minister has told Sky News
that an international body should now
take over the investigation the UN
sanction ICAO
ICAO stands for is a acronym for
International Civil Aviation
Organization and they do have their own
and their own independent prop
independent investigation into any
catastrophe of this nature and may be I
think is good to trigger this initiative
this investigation so that so that
nobody would ever say that you know
certain parties have something to befall
[Music]
and so the search of the South China Sea
is now over but rescue teams now face
the prospect of a new enemy which is
much bigger much harder this has become
a criminal investigation but is it a
murder inquiry for the first time since
the plane went missing and the prospect
that it has landed somewhere has become
a genuine possibility next who else was
on board we are now started to learn
about the personal stories behind the
227 missing passengers
my emotion is going through what a
roller coaster ride these movements are
consistent with deliberate action by
someone on the plane what happened to
Malaysia Airlines mh370 has continued to
battle the world rescue teams are
searching an area more than 10 million
square miles with the task they face is
daunting
within that vast space they are looking
for an object which even in one piece is
only 63 meters now a Boeing triple7 air
[Music]
as the days go by without sign of the
plane or a clue as to its whereabouts
the uncertainty is becoming unbearable
for the waiting families and we are also
learning more about their loved ones the
personal stories of flight mh370
could the manifest hold the answers
investigators are scrutinizing every
name on it
they say remarkably they still haven't
received details for each passenger
after all this time the passenger
manifest is obviously very important it
enables you to identify all the persons
that are on board the aircraft and that
obviously is important for the security
of the aircraft but the Chinese
authorities insist they have done their
bit China has investigated the
backgrounds of all Chinese passengers on
board the missing Malaysia Airlines
flight mh370 and has found no evidence
suggesting they are linked to
destructive behavior on the aircraft so
we can rule out the suspicion that
Chinese passengers are linked to a
terror attack or destructive activities
on the missing plane
fifteen different nationalities were
flying to Beijing that night among them
153 from China 38 from Malaysia five
Indians for French three from the United
States and two Iranian zhan board who
became initial suspects that seemed to
have been ruled out thirty-five-year-old
jookin is a stuntman who's due to start
work on a new series of Netflix in
Malaysia next week he was on his way to
Beijing to see his two young children
Bob and Cathy Lawton are from to
Springfield Lakes in Australia they have
three daughters and a described as
doting grandparents
salamat bin omar has been waiting at a
kuala lumper hotel for any news his son
is an aviation engineer he was on his
way back to Beijing to repair private
jets because he has obvious knowledge of
aircraft he too is now under suspicion
[Music]
when the news came about it broke my
heart because the aircraft was lost he
didn't fall he didn't crash it just
disappeared sorry Appa ha yes I
understand and we do hope that the
investigators do investigate in my
opinion all I know is that my son is an
engineer for private jet and not huge
Boeing planes
[Music]
let's recap the planes last known
movements flight mh370 took off from
Kuala Lampur airport for Beijing on
Saturday the 8th of March at 12:41 a.m.
local time the last transmission from
the planes onboard communication system
ACARS
was previously said to be 7 minutes past
1 were now told though it could have
been switched off up to 30 minutes later
it has also been revealed that the last
verbal contact from the plane to air
traffic control was at 19 minutes past
111 minutes earlier than previously said
it is emerged for the first time as well
that the last words from the cockpit
were spoken by the copilot before the
planes transponder which tracks it was
turned off the next known location for
the airliner came after it turned west
it was picked up on military radar over
the Andaman Sea after that its location
is unknown but we do know that a
satellite received a signal from the
plane at 11 minutes past 8 in the
morning from a distance that puts it in
one of two flight corridors according to
new information investigators believe
that if the plane flew along the
northern corridor it would have reached
from Laos to the Caspian Sea depending
on how fast it was flying to the south
the search spans from Sumatra in
Indonesia to the southern Indian Ocean
some of the deepest waters on earth we
also know that the plane had enough fuel
to fly for around five hours after it
was last seen on radar off Malaysia
depending on the altitude it was flying
that would mean it could have traveled
anywhere within this range
it leaves a likely search area covering
a huge swathe of the globe based on the
data we know it has been calculated that
the plane could have landed at one of
634 runways in 26 countries across the
region if that is it was capable of
doing so but India Pakistan Kazakhstan
and Kyrgyzstan have said they didn't
detect any suspicious aircraft movement
in their airspace there's going to be
some systematic searching by by by
military crimes and aircraft which quite
frankly will be the best systems
available much of the space technology
is not necessarily directed at the area
that the aircraft is believed to have
gone down and it's not necessarily going
to be the right kind of space-based
surveillance system to pick up the kind
of debris or clues to the existence of a
crashed aircraft so I think it will rely
very much on the on the numbers of
reconnaissance at maritime
reconnaissance aircraft that are now
flocking to help the Malaysians with
their search with so little news as to
the planes whereabouts the relationship
between passengers and officials is
getting worse by the day I mean they've
been avoiding their responsibilities and
talking nonsense there are a lot of
contradictory answers to our questions
that makes us very angry I'm angry that
the Malaysians don't tell the truth
they lie to the whole world I'm totally
frustrated about this where is my son
even taxis have GPS they can be found if
they are lost or stolen it's a huge
plane so high-tech and so advanced how
could it not be found it's a joke
Paul weeks is a mechanical engineer he
accidentally left his wedding ring and
watch behind at home
when he traveled to Mongolia for work
[Music]
Hadrian watch her loss on the right is
17
Chao Yan on the left 18 together they
were on their way to school in Beijing
[Music]
34-yard who Chow Ling was on his way
home with his three-year-old daughter
who see one there are 239 people missing
lost on flight mh370 these are the
stories of just some of them
[Music]
you